so there's not going to be a jury trial
you heard this they're not going to be a
jury trial because apparently his lawyer
forgot to check a box on the phone I
don't know I don't know I don't know
about that
you don't have a jury of your peers in
New York City right you have a whole
bunch of crazy leftists that will of
course automatically no matter what
happens no matter what evidence is
provided automatically to say Trump bad
Trump jail but someone could double
check it but I think they're now that's
what they're saying that that they
didn't check a box right that's what's
going to happen either Trump's lying or
the judge is lying I think the strategy
here ask yourself why would Donald Trump
actually show up for this court case
when the judge already agent a summary
judgment dissolving the Trump
organization they want to file an appeal
so they don't want to waste your time
with a jury that's pointless it's going
to cost them more money all that stuff's
a waste of time they get their ruling
run it through file the appeal get the
lower court get the lower court reversed
yeah that's what I think is happening as
well because it doesn't make sense to
have a jury trial the judge is going to
be deciding here we saw a video of him
today and he uh clearly really likes the
camera really likes the Limelight